salut à tous c'est envergure vous pensez
que vous connaissez cetto lundgren en
tout cas vous avez déjà entendu le nom
c'est certain c'est un grand escogriffe
très très long très très très très long
il est attendu dans le top 3 de la draft
nba 2022 il est déjà candidat évidemment
on va faire son profil tout simplement
dans ce podcast son profil détaillé pour
savoir où il en est ce qui lui manque
pour devenir une star et ce qu'ils
méritent d'être le numéro un de la draft
voilà le menu en bref 40 minutes pour
que notre chat famille grain génériques
et pour parler de cetto dans ce podcast
envergure on rappelle que s'afficher sur
envergure point c'est aussi voulait
avoir les stats sous les yeux puis le
scouting ne reporte écrit mais à l'oral
pour le moment nous avons une qui est là
pour parler du joueur de gonzague est à
saluer salut a tous très contents votre
heure à la une également
et puis notre spécialiste west coast qui
a vu énormément de matches évidemment de
gonzaga c'est julien salut je commence à
me ligue 1 ben écoute ça va bien on est
en place on commence à accélérer le
rythme des publications vous allez le
voir dans les prochains jours sur sur
envergure mais on va encore monter d'un
niveau puisque on approche tout
doucement de la draft et puis de la
loterie qui aura lieu dans la nuit du 17
au 18 mai chez tonnes de graines donc là
on commence à parler des gros gros noms
il est prévu dans le top 3 quasiment
dans toutes lés moque ou big board qu'on
connaît on va se poser des questions sur
son jeu mais d'abord on va se demander
quel est son parcours puisque c'est
important aussi pour connaître un joueur
alors d'où il vient château loudenne
alan chat qui vient du minnesota donc ça
fait quand même temps qu'on ne connaît
pas ce que il a le physique qui fait
qu'ils passent pas inaperçus
et donc en fait depuis qu'il est
fin collège début lycée pour nous que
depuis qu'il a 14 ou 15 ans on le voit
on le voit sur des sur des trous des
highlights on nous voyez sur des matches
et donc ensuite donc là il était à
l'académie minea avec jeanine size vous
souhaitez c'est une des meilleures
preuves school du minnesota ça devient
même une très très bonne proposition de
circuits lycéens
il avait beaucoup de matches en télé
nationale à l'époque dont un contrat
canyon qui avait été très très
regardé il fait une douce contre sur le
match dans une équipe face à donkey les
haïr williams qui joue à memphis
maintenant il y avait but chez boston
qui joue au petit pearl
il y avait un mari bay lèvres sur jean
rioux ciel et ensuite il a il est resté
à il est resté donc inapte et de son
cursus terminé haye s'est engagé à
gonzaga et en même temps il a été
champion du monde u 19 avec team usa et
mvp de la compétition
donc on lit beaucoup en france qui s'est
fait manger quant à victor wanyama si on
regarde le match c'est pas vraiment le
cas est ce qu'on disait tous à l'époque
c'est que ça en dise est sûrement plus
sur victor que sur check vous fait que
victorin tomine pardon mais voilà il a
toujours su sono room du tome janry
siens mcdonald's all american toutes les
récompenses et ils s'engagent à gonzaga
pour son année son année freshman et sa
seule année universitaire et il ya aussi
une famille de basketteurs de papa
l'oncle et tout ça parce qu on a son
parcours dont catch est une graine à
quoi il ressemble physiquement quelles
sont ses qualités athlétiques
on va demander ça à julian
leurs recettes il fait deux mètres 15 il
presque deux mètres d'envergure et 88 kg
86 kg je pense qu'on en reparlera plein
de détails donc physiquement et du beau
au niveau des cheveux c'est très
classique et puis sinon il ressemble un
peu à une
biscotte une cracotte quoi il est très
fin
et très long
donc voilà il a des bras laquelle vignes
durante et des jambes comme les bras de
kevin durant est il très fin sinon il
est
vrai que ça il est un gars qui est très
rapide qui est très facile verticalement
il peut aller assez vite il a une bonne
vitesse axe panier panier je pense que
hughes et adam sont comme moi ils ont
plein de petites vidéos on le voit
prendre des rebonds et couvrir avec ou
sans ballon jusqu'au cercle adverse
il a une sur des comptes il est dans la
raquette il a une bonne vivacité il
tourne vite sur ses hanches il est très
facile pour bouger pour se replacer dans
l'espace utilisé ses deux bras pour
gêner
c'est quelque chose dans tout va
reparler aussi je pense quand on parlera
de sa défense c'est un gars très dédié
et puis malgré
son gabarit très skinny comme on dit il
arrive à encaisser les coups les chocs
des pôles encore une fois hughes et
allen avait montré sa dans une de leurs
vidéos c'est quand même un gars qui est
très haut sur ses jambes et d'un son de
gravité assez haut
je pense qu'on peut dire qu'il manque de
puissance dans les jambes et
on le voit souvent quand il ya plus d
espace qui doit défendre
sur plus d espace il va un petit peu
s'emmêler les pieds où il a il peut
perdre de l'equilibre un petit peu
voilà moi j'ai noté qu' sur les grands
espaces il manque de collant au sol je
peux aussi vous pourrez dire ce à quoi
des bons voire donc
grand fin rapide est dédié il manque de
collant au sol j'adore
j'adore quand on invente des termes ici
à envergure c'est aussi ça le scouting
essayer de décrire des situations qui
sont
difficilement descriptible dans la vie
de tous les jours auquel on ne prête pas
attention en tout cas
pourquoi on parle de cetto m'bengue
comme d'un top 5 d'un top 3 d'un top 1
quelles sont ses qualités ses grandes
qualités basket en résumé hugh c'est
pour toi voilà c'est un joueur on en
parle aussi bien parce que ça mec qui va
arriver en nba et qui va changer une
équipe et deux côtés du terrain
clairement les franchises qui vont
drafté dans les top trois top-5 elle
espère avoir le franchise player en tout
cas le mec qui peut changer la dynamique
une une équipe qui est négative qu'a
manque de talent et c'est lui va arrive
en 1ère année offensivement c'est un peu
on est toujours par les discordances et
une grande mode mais lui les dents les
caractéristiques de la licorne qui peut
tout faire sur un terrain de basket et
comme alan le dit très bien souvent
c'est que quand un joueur qu'il ne
devrait pas être capables de faire ce
qui fait quand la démonstration physique
comme les siennes ça mais
qu'effectivement qui est très mobile il
peut marquer de toutes les positions sur
un terrain de basket dans tous les
secteurs avec dans plusieurs situations
dribbler passer chuté c'est un joueur
qui malgré le fait qu'ils se soient fins
ont rencontré dans les détails qui peut
avoir un impact dès sa première année
parce qu'il a dominé le circuit n 6 et
avec des pourcentages totalement
indécent sur tous les secteurs et une
vraie vraie bonne finition de nouveau au
panier comme on pourra la broad un peu
plus tard et puis de l'autre côté du
terrain défensivement c'est un gars qui
te créer un système défensif et ça les
franchises qui sont souvent les plus
faibles ondées des bilans défensive
vraiment faible avec un manque de
cohésion manque de cohérence et lui peut
arriver en première année changer la
géométrie sur le terrain modifier le
fait que les portant de ballades disent
pas accéder au panier
julien il l'a dit les mobiles tu vas
pouvoir aller sur différents profils sur
différents secteurs du jeu sortir un peu
plus reprendre donc c'est vraiment un
mec très jeune tu peux tout construire
autour de lui il peut à peu près tout
faire elle va falloir juste le
développer comme tu sens et c'est une
pépite très très rare et sabots nombre
très très cher on passe aux questions
qu'ils se posent sur cetto une graine on
assez grande qualité basket on reviendra
sur la technique un petit peu après mais
moi ce que j'aime faire quand on parle
surtout des top top top prospects c'est
d'aller essayer de gratter sur la
mentalité sur ce qui ressort du joueur
son attitude sur et en dehors du terrain
puisque quand on est drafté très haut on
attend de vous des trains un leader et
donc est ce que tu sais ton grain a ça
dans le sang est ce qu'il l'a déjà est
ce qu'il est en progression est ce qu'il
est en train de le travailler je
commence par toi julien a vu énormément
de matches de gonzaga je vais te
demander d'abord sur le terrain de chez
tonnes de graines il est comment
humainement
il arrivait un goon saga dans une équipe
qui était une académie de basket comme
on dit donc il n'a pas il avait pas être
le leader on n'a pas demandé de leader
il y en avait déjà un en attaque
et
voilà donc il s'est insérée dans un
collectif il a très bien fait donc ça
c'est un premier point important
kleib qu'il avait à l'âne en a parlé
et puis au niveau de son caractère on
pouvait se poser des questions quand un
syndicat une drôle de une drôle de tête
on se demande parfois s'il est content
d'être sur le terrain mais en fait pas
du tout il est un type qui est hyper
impliqué dans ce qui fait je pense ça se
voit
oui il réagit quand il prend des fautes
qui n'aime pas
mais c'est toujours très positif alors
c'est difficile de commandes est en tout
cas il est cadré dans cette équipe donc
peut-être que si elle a aidé comme tu
dis je ne sais pas trop quelle était sa
mentalité à venger du quelques
interviews enfin quelques articles là où
notamment succès d'autres de ses
coéquipiers comme s'il était un rail
school parler de vie et ça a toujours
été un type focaliser sur le travail
focalisé sur comment il voulait
progresser c'est un type qui n'a pas
toujours joué pivot ou intérieure il est
passé il est passé de guarda flux ndi
pour finir dans la raquette et il a
toujours fait progresser son jeu donc je
pense que c'est un type qui a une
mentalité de gagneur
et puis
voilà son père basketteur qui
apparemment a été présent dans sa
formation qui le pose si je pendant dans
son évolution et puis on peut dire quand
même que avec toute sorte ou les des
projecteurs qui ont été braqués sur lui
il a lille une progression qui est
constante je pense que ça c'est
important de voir qu'il va qu'est
projeté tome 1 et qui a garé de garder
la tête sur les épaules partout où il
est passé de team usa laissent couler
ils vont nous engueuler après les
épaules qu'il a pourtant bien frêle
d'ailleurs mais une mauvaise
plaisanterie mise à part effectivement
c'est quelqu'un qui a l'air d'avoir les
pieds sur terre chat holmgren hugues
alan qu'est ce que vous avez à dire vous
avez peut-être lu des interviews vous
êtes vous avez vous aussi regarder des
matchs dans l'attitude sur le terrain
sur le banc l'échauffement
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire de la
mentalité de châteaulin moi franchement
j'aime
déjà ce qu'il faut dire c'est que cela
n'a pas dérangé des fois de prendre le
deuxième ou troisième siège troisième
rôle dans une équipe quand il a fallu
vraiment avec team usa alors c'est
toujours plus facile quand tu es
intérieur que extérieur de faire ça
parce que tu as un moment là bas et a
plus besoin de la création des autres
donc forcément tu peux avoir un rôle
secondaire voire qu'à faire dans une
équipe mais c'est pas le plus leader
vocalement c'est pas le leader
émotionnellement mais par contre comme
je lé des leaders par l'exemple c'est
certain que c'est qui va au charbon en
fait et qui en qui il a dit qu'il avait
déjà dit dans des interviews il s'en
fiche en fait de se faire postérisé ou
de faire peut-être sur des photos de se
faire croquer ou ça il s'est fait cros
et c'est en entendant cette année c'est
déjà fait postérisé aussi par le passé
mais il va à chaque fois et c'est
vraiment
des tarés de l'as côté assez et c'est
marrant assez animal quand il est sur le
terrain c'est à dire que il est vraiment
là pour pour anéantir toute attaque
adverse vers son panier vert pour
défendre comme une vraie tour de
contrôle et après ça quelqu'un peut il a
un peu là je trouve un peu fort mais
comment champions depuis peu de piger
très jeune avec le père circuit under
armour déjà très jeunes mis en avant
les interviews sont bonnes il parle pas
donc trop trop mais je pense que c'est
un pas ce qu'il ya à la fois s'est
renfermé hors terrain et sur le terrain
il devient un peu un peu un peu fou
parents non mais c'est assez contrôlé
quand même ouais moi je rejoins ce que
disent que dieu donne là dessus ça se
voit sur le terrain effectivement quand
on partage le rôle qu'elle joue contre
le texas par exemple trou timmy qui est
le leader français de l'équipe à julien
de décrire une gros leaders wazemmes
c'est durruti mais l'autre intérieur
moustachu concours qu'on aide on essaie
de s'inspirer tous les jours tant bien
que mal capillairement et parle on est
con ce mec là dominent le jeu face à
texas qui est en grosse rencontre lui
lui donne tous les bonnes idées at il
posté au il lui fournit tous les ballons
pas de souci je marquerai 5 6 points sur
un showcase qui est jolie espionne n'y a
pas de problème tant qu'on gagne le
match
la dernière je reproche pas mal à evans
mobile de manquer d'agressivité
disent que c'est en alpha et c'est sur
le terrain et romane le disait tu fais
pas 3 contres par match quand et pas
agressif et là on a un joueur qui à 3,7
contre par match et on a un joueur qui
finit à 90% près du panier donc je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de problème avec le
contact je pense qu'il ya pas de
problème de si on doit marque un panier
de pouvoir le mettre par contre je pense
que c'est important de dire aux gens que
contrairement à certains prospects du
top 4 ça va pas être un mec qui va que
julien me dit dans le titre de l'essai
mobley jamais jamais julien et les
condamnés avant une carrière où je vais
le tacler dès que je peux
ça va être un des rares mecque du top 5
de top 4 de la draft qui va pas être un
bug est meilleur il peut marquer de tous
les dix ans pas de souci mais ça peut
être un gars qui va dire donnez moi le
ballon je vais tirer je vais tirer je
vais tirer je vais tirer là où les
bonnes qui roulait à villé jabbari smith
sont au plus haut ce modèle donc
effectivement drafté cet engrais ne sais
pas non plus avoir un mec qui va prendre
le ballon et qui va essayer de scorer
sur toutes les possessions moi ce que je
voulais aussi rajouter parce que hughes
a dit les pourcentages et souvent ce
qu'on a dit pas mal cette année c'est
ouais mais c'est la wct gère pas que
parce que souffrant sur la première
partie de l'année tu peux me lama devait
cesser la donc la west coast conférence
la conférence de gonzague et en gros
chaque année pourquoi quand un gars
arrivent à la march madness des fois
avec zéro défaite une ou deux parce
qu'il joue dans une conférence qui est
pas dans les six plus grosses
conférences mais déjà le conseil à
chaque année en novembre décembre donc
la période hors match conférence ils ont
ils planifient des gros matches qu'ils
ont joués diu qu'ils ont faite ex
assiégées texas tech qu'ils ont joués
alabama ils ont joué tout bronzé qui
pointent jeu j'en oublie j'en oublie
même et ensuite awcc cette année ces
trois équipes par la march madness donc
san francisco
[Musique]
ca de maîtrise et gonzague a laissé deux
équipes au hédas ici donc be why your
way santa clara c'est plus des cinq que
certaines grosses fois qu'on a envoyés
sur ces deux tours voilà donc en fait
c'est à nuancer de franchement oui en
terme des sépales habituel c'est pas là
ici mais il y avait un bon niveau dans 2
apa sur dominer comme des prospects sur
dominent des fois on est vraiment petite
conférence sinusal je voulais maintenant
oui on parle de wcc moi j'ai revu le
match contre san diego qui est vraiment
un programme très modeste en fait en ewc
et pour parler de son de 127 au début du
match c'est quand même un peu pourrir
par le pivot de san diego et il est sa
réaction est assez violente en trois
axes un de ses meilleurs matches de la
saison après donc c'est quand même un
gars qui a comme
il est d'accord un certain moment pour
passer le ballon mais si on joue trop il
m'a montré beaucoup de choses et ça
reste toujours dans le cadre de l'équipe
parce qu'il
il est à déduire scorer dessus et
combien de contribuer dans le match que
ce n'était pas moi il a du caractère
c'est ce qui ressort de ce que vous
dites on va maintenant parler de sa
défense puisque c'est quand même pour ça
en tout cas sans ça il ne serait pas
dans la conversation du top 3 du top 1
même de la prochaine draft donc sa
défense c'est sa carte de visite sauf
que l'éléphant dans la pièce la chose
dont tout le monde parle et on va à
l'évacuer tout de suite c'est qui pèse
88 kg je crois que c'est ce qu'a dit
julien tout à l'heure pour de mettre 15
effectivement c'est peu c'est trop peu
on est tous d'accord là dessus
maintenant à quel point ça va influencer
sa défense dans les premières années
et est ce que ça peut le pénaliser à
long terme on va commencer par
rafah quand tu as des ces gros éléphant
au milieu de la pièce là le poids de
cetto drainant peuvent arriver trop mais
qui va se faire défoncer par an
mi-janvier
comme tous les pivots nba
ça déjà voilà être capable de défendre
son duel en bits personne peut le faire
donc je mets c'est un peu de côté
si elle souhaiterait ne tirez pas trois
points et il n'avait pas cet arsenal
offensif ça poserait problème de fer 88
kg parce qu'en fait ça limiterait la
manière dont il peut être incorporé dans
certains line up parce qu'aujourd'hui en
nba en réalité
il faut avoir qu'un seul jour
qui heurte qu'on spacing sur le terrain
tu certaines équipes arrivent à sur ie
avec deux mais c'est parce qu'elles sont
vraiment des joueurs élites
offensivement dansez dansez line up là
les net's pas raison par moments dans la
saison régulière mais en réalité cet
amour haine comme on prouve qu'on
prévoit qui tire à trois points comme
l'a dit luc 72% lancers francs à deux
mètres 15 à 20 ans on peut acheter le
tir quasiment 40% à 3 points utilisable
sur pick and pop et tout ça c'est parce
que j'utilise d'abord l'argument
offensif pour venir sur la défense mais
pour moi c'est lui parce qu'en fait
comme il va être capable de ne pas
heurter ton expecting tu vas pouvoir le
mettre dans les premiers temps en nba
avec un intérieur qui ne tirent pas trop
points donc dans ce qu'on imagine à
l'intérieur naturel grand opus proche du
panier ce qui a été un petit peu le cas
avec eva noblet qu'on a positionné dans
l'est dans les premiers temps avec jared
allen ce qui lui a permis de ne pas être
en contact direct avec les intérieurs
qui sont plus puissants et qui font
forcément sur du post up le mettre à mal
mais qui vont permettre à dire est à
evans mobley d'être dans un rôle de
second rideau ce qui est un petit peu
janice entité ocampo derrière book lopez
qui robert williams derrière al horford
aux celtics ce que les ricains musée
magnin appelle le rôle de romer donc la
deuxième lame et chet il est très bon
sur ça parce qu'il ya un très bon ique
il a une bonne vision je pense qu'il
anticipe bien donc en fait comme on
projette qui tire à propos on va pouvoir
dans le premier temps le maître avec ce
genre d'intérieur là ce qui pourra
régler un peu au début le problème de
poids qui est un problème il faut le
dire
et puis pour que pour compléter un peu
là-dessus même en termes de poids moi
j'invite les gens à regarder le match
pendant la semaine des as contre memphis
où il a pu jouer face à challenger n le
pivot qui domine physiquement le match
c'est pas de challenger n est naturel il
est comparé à certains athlètes comme
dwight howard et c'est donc oui il est
il est mince mais ça va franchement très
très vite aller parce que il avril vraie
puissance au niveau du bassin il un vrai
équilibre là dessus donc ça va se faire
au fur et à mesure et comme alan le 10
fois la défense sur les ailiers il à la
mobilité pour pouvoir orienter revenir
faire du second rideau pour voir un
petit peu sortir et c'est donc en fait
tu peux le mettre dans quasiment tous
les systèmes alors il switch sera
sûrement pas sur les arrières mais
encore une fois
beaucoup de pivot qui souhaitent sur les
arrières qui n'est pas d'abord n'est pas
ma départ n'est pas ben hamad et bayod
qui veut et encore même lit les poches
aux cailles robin donc il ya aucun
problème je penche sur l'adaptation
qu'en nba très rapidement défensif
julien tu disais tout à l'heure qui
s'emmêlait un petit peu les pinceaux est
ce que tu peux me parler des couvertures
de pick and roll puisqu'il entend
défendre beaucoup évidemment nba des
couvertures de pick and roll à gonzaga
est ce qui s était varié ce qu'il est
bon en drop mais aussi alors on va pas
rentrer dans les termes ultra technique
mais ans accompagnés reprendre en sortir
et reprendre en switch également qu est
ce que tu peux nous dire là-dessus ouais
c'est ça il
doit pas très bien comment ce que j'ai
vu je suis pas un grand spécialiste du
droit et du edge et dieu a aidé mais il
drogue très bien et c'est un peu même ça
c'est ce qui fait sa force il fait peur
il fait peur avant de de faire des
contre ça qui est important à mon avis
ce qui change complètement la tacc
adverse parce qu'il fait peur et
il sait défendre ça parce qu'ils les
voient là et il est rapide il est vive
sur continuer dans la raquette moi je le
trouve très vif pour se retourner pour
changer de direction aussi son terreau
sauté après
il a des bras très précis il joue avec
ses deux bras cec du cy young ou adam
qui ont balancé un truc sur mumbai
annassers à la demande tout à l'heure
et je pense qu'il ne sait pas si le fait
aussi bien non plus d'un grand
spécialiste mais il le fait quoi il sait
utiliser ses deux bras pour contrer ce
qui est difficile
donc
voilà le pick-and-roll il sait le
défendre aussi pour tous à toutes ces
raisons parce qu'il est assez
bon ok je ne suis pas d'accord moi je
trouve qu'il est il est pas mal en pick
and roll si si et moi je disais qu'en
fait si tu veux je n'avais vu tomber au
championnat du monde deux trois fois et
j'en avais parlé ensemble et c'est ce
qu'a dit hugues on m'a dit tu as
entièrement raison /
sur des personnes
écoutées et c'est sur ce genre de truc
où il va il va tomber ou quand ils
traversent aussi des fins et comme il
est léger aussi je sais pas si c'est
peut-être à cause de ça quand ils
continuent à apprendre des écrans bas
cette future et après c'est pas du tout
peut-être que j'étais un peu dur au
début mais il va sûrement gonflé un
petit peu des jambes du corps du haut du
corps aussi à des deux vont être à
pousser et puis il tiendra me collera
mieux
il sera plus collants
c'est la cuisson du riz en fait mon
poêle de cuisson du riz faut toujours
que tu rapportes ça ton plat du soir
mais si on va parler de l' attaque on va
parler de l' attaque parce que
c'est très important on peut pas on peut
pas se permettre d'être un top 3 de
draft et de rien apporté offensivement à
son équipe on dit chez tom grain c'est
la licorne parce que il sait faire plein
de choses notamment tiré sauf que il
sait tirer ça veut un peu tout et rien
dire hugues est ce que tu peux me
détailler un peu il s'est tiré dans quel
contexte
est ce que c'est une gestuelle régulière
est-ce que ça rentre de la même manière
des deux côtés du terrain est ce qu il a
des préférences motrice au niveau du tir
voilà est-ce que tu peux rentrer dans le
détail ouais bien sûr
effectivement ça oui c'est un geste
qu'on achète le tir comme tu l'as dit il
et moi je trouve régulier rapide
distance nba ce qui est assez incroyable
le joueur sait qu'il n'a pas peur de tir
en transition on le verra je trouve
beaucoup de séquences en syrie remonte
la balle il tire en premier attention de
transition donc c'est un mec qui est
vraiment confiance là dedans ça n'est
déjà un excellent jour de pick and pop
sa lettre elle des choses les plus
demandés pour lyon nba si vous regardez
la chaude charte actuellement il a pris
je vous dis ça dans laxe il a pris 61
tirs à trois points et c'est
majoritairement des tirs qui va prendre
un petit yann pop qui pose est très très
bon écran qui veut créer de l'impact et
c'est quelque chose que je critique
souvent chez les jeunes américains des
très mauvais écran qui font du slip
rolland fait lui s'est déjà amené ça ce
qui est assez impressionnant aussi c'est
qu'ils peuvent tirer lui en sortie
d'écran alors je ne sais pas si on va
lui demander de faire sans une billets
mais moi j'aime bien le fait qu'ils
puissent serait axé face au panier
retourner face au panier et déclencher
ce que je regardais aussi c'est est ce
qu'il y avait une différence côté gauche
côté droit niveau du tir à trois points
on sait que très souvent les droitiers
ils vont avoir une préférence motrices
lorsque la balle elle arrive directement
sur leurs mains pour pouvoir déclencher
donc la balle elle arrive depuis leur
côté qu'elles sont à la gauche s'en fait
du passeur et 8 des deux côtés du
terrain c'est homogène on a le même
pourcentage sur le même ni volume ça
veut dire que ça mais qui est assez à
l'aise pour vitré axé sa balle au niveau
de la main et déclencher n'obtienne la
répétition motrices qu'était effectué là
dessus et quand tu parles de toucher au
niveau du panier près du cercle on a
aussi un mec qui est vraiment qui est
vraiment efficace qui est vraiment
fluide on est sur la sur la zone donc
qu'on s'écarte un petit peu vraiment de
la raquette on est chauds du 66 % dans
la zone qui s'appelle in the paint
surtout ce qui va être les petits et les
petits bras roulé les petit flotteur et
tout ça donc on est largement au-dessus
de la moyenne n'diaye et on a un mec qui
poste bas alors même si c'est pas un
joueur de post bac il ya quand même des
moves dont un fait de way incroyable qui
t'a travail sur dirk nowitzki 1 le one
leg d'heure qu on sait pas s'ils veulent
le faire à tous les matchs on a vu de
très très beaux one leg de façade ou par
exemple on s'est dit ah ok donc le
gaillard vrai répertoire donc un tir que
j'achète vraiment où tous les niveaux
est intéressant ce que tu dit hulk parce
qu on note déjà
ses go to move on va dire
dont on a besoin en nba on a besoin de
moov voilà qui qui vont fonctionner très
régulièrement donc tu t'en a cité deux
pendant pendant ta description tu as
parlé de ce one leg donc à la dup même
si c'est pas ils montrent pas le genou
aux seahawks d'arc et et de ce trois
points en transition qui est très bas à
l'époque quand il était à texas kevin
durant ne faisait ça il le fait toujours
en une bienne non patchées paul breyne
soit kevin durand tu m'aimais il ya des
airs sur cette action la honte
on le compare donc hadja barry smith à
paulo banque héros qui sont tous les
deux avec lui dans le top 3 potentiel de
la draft
deux joueurs qui ont des qualités
offensives on va dire plus évidente à
qui on va peut-être plus donner le
ballon en mode alpha à quel niveau
offensif tchèque qui change beaucoup de
choses défensivement à quel niveau
offensif il a besoin d'être pour pouvoir
être considéré meilleur que ces deux-là
plus important avec plus de valeur allen
pour moi il a besoin d'être
le jarret jackson de sa saison sophomore
qui shoote à 38 39 % 40 % à 3 points sur
un bon volume et qui est pas aussi de
finir très correctement et on oublié
donc proche du poignet médecin lancers
francs et prendre des décisions au bon
moment on a vu faire des bonnes passes
cette année n'était pas vraiment utilisé
sur short rose n'était pas vraiment
utilisé comme salomon l'a vu faire des
renversements et de trouver des couples
in de fond c'est vrai le jeu de gonzague
à s'y prêtait pas ce que c'est vraiment
ça ajoute ça joue très très bien même
s'il ya beaucoup de turn over chaque
année mais pour moi là il a besoin
d'être
j'avais dit j'avais dit quand on avait
fait un gros épisode un peu sur le haut
de la draft en janvier ou fin décembre
que pour moi c'était le seul joueur qui
avait une excuse élite dans cette draft
et c'était ça c'est sa protection de
cercle s'accroissait tour de contrôle ce
qui faisait qu'ils avaient en un
je suis un peu remonté sur un genre
comme paolo gontero depuis très
honnêtement notamment sur la qualité de
passe pour moi c'est le meilleur passeur
de quasiment le meilleur passeur d'art
et il est tellement puissant qui peut se
créer pas mal de choses sans mais chet
s'il est capable sur un os vous informe
volume de tirer à trois points c'est à
dire cinq six tentatives par match
quasiment 40%
faire des bonnes passes je pense qu'il
peut quand même toujours mérité d'être
des plans de miroir parce que la
capacité à changer comment on est
attaqué quand tu es sur le terrain elle
ne changera pas il est toujours là et
ses adversaires cette polyvalence aussi
de l'utilisation de par l'ocha extérieur
julien est ce que tu imagines un
scénario pour chat en nba dans lequel ça
fonctionnerait pas
je pense que si on lui fit label tru au
poste qu'on attend trop de lui
qu'il a fait c'est bon mais
la question ne s'est pas trop de
moi j'ai surtout vu ça comme si on veut
trop lui en demander offensivement tout
de suite ouais c'est intéressant il va
falloir un front office un coaching
staff plutôt très créatif pour pour pas
se contenter de faire juste du pick and
pop un hugues c'est un truc dont je
parlais d'ailleurs quand j'avais été
invité par les amis d'aider des fans des
roquettes
pour pour parler un peu de la saison 2
de leur rookie et ce soir-là il jouait
contre les caps les caves par non et je
leur disais la manière dont cleveland
utiliser vannes moby offensivement
pour moi c'est vraiment le blueprint
sait ce qu'il faut faire pour
l'utilisation des grands au profil un
peu bizarre pour les années à venir
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut faire
hugues est ce que tu es d'accord avec ça
il pour pour vraiment tirer le maximum
de son potentiel il va falloir être un
peu créatif ouais je pense qu'il va
falloir le tester tout ce que tu peux
faire de cette façon de se reposer de
reconstruction donc va falloir rester
deux jours tout ce que les joueurs
aiment faire sur tout ce que le joueur
peut faire ça va être une sorte de
laboratoire un peu un peu sympa
c'est toujours mieux d'être créatif de
toute façon une joie du beau basket
il va avoir besoin d'un extérieur
sûrement plus que les autres mecs dont
on va parler dans le top 14 samedi au
graff il va lui falloir un fort
extérieur evans mobile a eu la chance
d'avoir dans huit garlande comme dale
green a eu la chance d'avoir et gbagbo
blé effectivement il va il va lui
falloir salle avantage quand combien de
la draft c'est que les équipes faibles
là cette année elles ont quasiment tout
un très forte autour de bâle à qui
manque à un deuxième gros talent ou
moins en alpha voir un bon porteur de
balle quoi et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment lui la draft parfaite pour chat
en granit ont vraiment bien et j'ai peu
de scénarios de franchise là quand je
regarde les probabilités de l'autriche
en tant qu at-on tous les jours et émet
que je vois sur twitter où il y aurait
pas un dieu qui peut se faire extérieur
intérieur vraiment intéressant alan est
ce que tu partages ce constat il ya peu
de scénario dans lequel ça marche pas je
lisais d'ailleurs quelque chose de très
intéressant là dessus est ce que
finalement chet on n'a pas tendance à
sous-estimer sa valeur par rapport à ça
je m'explique si l'équipe par laquelle
il est drafté reste en bas de tableau il
est possible que dans les prochaines
années et draft d'autres joueurs
potentiellement superstar mais vu qu'il
a un profil très unique on va dire
sauf victor webb anyama mais voilà c'est
l'autre il ya peu de chance finalement
de sélectionner le même type de joueur
avec lui et donc il sera complémentaire
de cette potentielle autre star drafté
après lui c'est ça mais c'était comme
mobley l'année dernière aura été
peut-être qu'on avait par moments vous
évaluer avec la he arc du profil mais
scarlett c'est quasiment ça rajouterait
donc un fort porter devant la côte et
promettant des bonnes dispositions mais
surtout un autre intérieur je demande
pas jarrett n quelle limite de niveau
all stars mais même si la terre est
important de youssou ndour kitsch et
très bien déjà qu'ils jouent à côté d'un
joueur comme un joueur puissant qui va
être capable lui de prendre le premier
contact sur les gros intérieurs adverses
parce que la nba soir après soir c'est
dur les contacts à l'intérieur un
pouvoir ce que
pas que dans la série minocchi postone
donc ça s'envoie que des coups c'est
tout le temps que c'est très très
compliqué donc j'aimerais vraiment alors
oui le un créateur extérieur bien sûr
mais sagan fait car la nhtsa a été
l'accélérateur de particules pour mobile
est plus que ça je préfère une équipe où
il ya déjà peut-être un intérieur
puissant capable de jouer avec lui dès
le début si tu ne mets à orlando avec
wendell carter ça me vois franchement
l'association des deux jeeps ans si je
peux et je peux vraiment l'apprécier
après voilà si on veut mettre avec un
fort porteur de balle 20 tu ne m'as ok
si avec guy des houches et où tu le mets
à indiana avec avec guitare et à liberté
ça peut être ça peut être super
intéressant il sera toujours mis dans
les bonnes dispositions que ces jours là
mais moi j'ai vraiment j'insiste
vraiment a demandé à julien commence un
peu ratée ne pas fonctionner ça peut
rater si tu ne mets poste ça qui est
avec 4 shooteur au tour très tôt en
carrière ça marche presque aussi un
scénario qui ce passe mal ça scénario
lui fait vraiment beaucoup de riz blé on
a très très peu parlé c'est peut-être sa
plus grosse faiblesse le dribble comme
paul pourquoi est-ce qui peut pas autant
marqué que les autres c'est parce que
c'est pas un mec qui peut de pipe
postaux alors on l'a vu à faire de la
transition poser le ballon allait on est
allé jusqu'au cirque mais sur jeu placé
il ya un peu plus en difficulté quand
même depuis le postaux pour aller au
niveau du panier héliporté un peu moins
droite et change pas trop demain une en
spin mouftiez pas non plus
particulièrement assuré on a vu qu'en
lui-même un premier contact perdre un
peu le contrôle de son ballon sur
certains dribbles et ben n'oubliant
dernier par exemple moi je trouve
accéder plus facilement au panier depuis
la ligne des lancers-francs chat c'est
peut-être sa plus grosse faiblesse dans
son jeu il faut bien qu'on en est à 19
ans 20 ans sinon ça serait juste 32 15
sur tout
ça
donc peut-être voilà une erreur ce
serait de lui dire bon bah écoute tel
projet de reconstruction prend les
ballons et puis débrouille toi et eva au
cercle et on le fait trop dribbler trop
dribbler et à pour son casque quoi de
mentalement et physiquement même si
mentalement il a l'air costaud pour
encaisser les coups julien est ce que tu
as quelque chose à ajouter donc que tu
n'as pas dit qu'ils étaient sur ton
carnet de notes
donc apparu ce sont donc deux fautes qui
est raisonnable pour le gars qui qui
défend beaucoup parlé pour d'autres
postés
par rapport aux un jardin vie ou par
rapport à oui par rapport à jahren
jackson seront alan parlé plus tôt voilà
il est raisonnable de nous
oui il a raison il envoie le fait que
c'est un très bon rebondeur 9 à 10
ça vient avec son
son explosif sa vitesse verticale ouais
c'est un des premiers en haut et pas
seulement parce qu'il a des longs bras
assez intéressant
et très bon sur le second saut ce n'est
quand même du bien très tôt j'ai mis
deux trois clips c'est hyper
impressionnant
personnes directement après font par le
passé
ça c'est forcément beaucoup de travail
aussi puisque je pense pas que
naturellement c'est quelqu'un qui est un
second sera pillé pas à yom quoi ton
très content mais voilà moi j'aime hip
hop us d'actifs tandis que hig j'ai dit
moi personnellement j'y mets rarement
mis petit bac dans ma vie peut-être que
je n'ai pas assez travailler peut-être
que je vais juste à 1083 vous voyez
comment luc tu as des choses à ajouter
sur thien nhan en nombre moi je les
regarde ma moque
je n'ai pas numéro 1 n'insultez pas
c'est juste que j'aime bien les
créateurs balle en main donc je prie
billy toujours les quatre ballons n'en
est sûrement que l'an prochain j'aurai
scouts henderson et on me demandait jour
discorde pourquoi pas chez toi un bon
ben voila je réponds ici vite fait parce
que moi je préfère toujours un mec qui
peut prendre le ballon dans n'importe
quel contexte bon ou mauvais et est
marqué 20 points très rapidement donc
voilà pourquoi chez moi paulo au lot
devant allan chez toi il est sur le même
titre que les autres et ce qu'il est un
tiers au dessus un tiers au dessous vous
savez j'ai deux genres dans mon tir 1
c'est lui et pour le brunch héros et
puis ça je suis vraiment assez sûr que
ça va rester c'est comme ça depuis
quelques années quelques mois après
qu'on a dit voilà c'est
sûrement plus simple dans les premières
années en nba pour paulo parce qu'il est
un peu plus mature physiquement il a le
jeu qui fait qu'on peut plus facilement
le mettre en avant ce surtout
offensivement parce que tu es forcément
il a quand même des lacunes qui sont qui
sont notables mais non je referai quand
même chez temps je pense parce que la
rareté du profil comme tu l'as dit et le
potentiel est fou et comme je l'aï dit
je me suis toujours assez comme fait que
si je dois retire une qualité lesquels
prospal a été la plus élites de cette
voie pas pour moi c'est la capacité de
tour de contrôle défensive deutsch est
donc j'irai là dessus c'est aussi signe
que dans cette draft ya pas de de luca
de quelques niña mais tout ça donc je
prendrais je prendrais j'attends ça peut
être l'homme graines à tout faire
vous avez envie de le voir ou chet donc
dans quel dans quelle franchise il ya
plusieurs équipes qui peuvent avoir le
fort ce pic entre ici ok ici détroit
ok si pardon mais c'est la seule équipe
que tu as cité cas pas de deuxième grand
pour f tout ça mais en fait ils ont deux
choix dans le top 10 avec les clippers
donkey draft lui et du renne quand il
est réglé
ou alors ils investissent sur un free
agent je sais voir mais avec guider et
chez fait vraiment et puis ça te assez
folklorique je pense que c'est parce que
les mecs qu'ils ont peut être chances de
virer leur vie où ils sont tombés il va
être top tron qu'on espère que le destin
peut se rattraper pour peut-être
pourquoi autant de sympathie pour cette
équipe chance s'équilibre ok si
toi tu es un vieux qui si huawei
tellement bien toi des trois noms à côté
des retraites permet en plus moi s'il
restitue leurs devoirs dessus content
c'est un joueur que j'aime beaucoup
ouest detroit même si j'aimerais vous
beaucoup de jabbar oui ça du tout et
tout donc peut-être voilà mais
j'ai pas trop vive houston parce que
j'ai le jeu j'ai peur qu'il soit un peu
perdu désolé aux fans de houston
vraiment je mets toute la commune aux
deux héros des roquettes dès qu'ils
aient tout mais j'ai peur qu'ils soient
pas d'entrer dans la mentalité de
houston avec beaucoup de jeunes un peu
comment dire un peu fou pour le dire
gentiment un peu dans la chaîne et c'est
avec diane greene qui avait une pointe
haute j'ignorais que c est que lui
correspond pas trop là dessus donc j'ai
peur qu'il soit un peu perdue là dessus
mais c'est vrai qu'il a plus une
identité de cols bleus tschetter du
minnesota
il fait très peur on fêtera les pistols
tu vas
des villes avec un passé automobile pour
cetto une graine
il va faire de la pub pour general
motors il ya une probable où ils
arrivent au pélican julien tu as une
préférence toi maintenant j'ai repensé à
tout vous avez dit auquel celle que
beaucoup ça peut être marrant il faut
être sur des métiers de voir toutes les
deux combinés sur le terrain ça pour
être fin c'est le fun tu es vraiment
pour tes vraiment là pour l'art quoi
l'expérience
en fait je cherchais avait avec un grand
quoi parce qu'il faut bien qu'un gros
épais donc vous cherchez à ok s'il ya
beaucoup comme dans les plf est
maintenant dans les autres équipes rhône
a cité il ya 100
g à d avec un écueil qui qui joue avec
lui ça pourrait être super joli coup à
orlando avec son ami jay z avec son pote
save carter et au franchement way
et franz wagner il ya plein de scénarios
canon c'est ça qui est bien avec le
profil de che tonnes de graines et c'est
ça que qu'on doit retenir en partie de
ce podcast qu'est que vous pouvez
écouter sur toutes les plateformes donc
abonnez vous pour recevoir la
notification podcast sort on a également
un profil à l'écrit sur notre site et
puis on a également des vidéos sur not
you tube d analyse vidéo avec du film et
en même temps huguet et allan qui
commentent ou ux et sur notre chaîne
envergure sur youtube ou sur envergure
replay puisqu'on a on a deux chaînes
les deux cas on à faire ouais on à faire
avec alan un premier live ensemble ou on
a vraiment de discuter de tous les deux
chez vanessa c'est sur la chaîne youtube
on parle de jane et caetera et sur la
chaîne replay il ya quand je fais une
version un peu solo et que je mets
vraiment le droit 0,5 pour les nerd donc
voilà vous avez les deux versions
possibles et comme vous préférez voilà
donc on est complet si vous voulez vous
vous renseigner sur chet en grain merci
beaucoup de nous avoir écoutés et puis
de toute façon vous donne rendez vous
très bientôt
suite à la loterie puisqu'on a prévu
toute une série de lives un par équipe
du top 8 qui aura le choix dans le top 8
un live par équipe à chaque fois une
heure avec l'analyse bah voilà de la
situation de l'équipe des besoins les
questions sur les prospects qui est ce
qu'ils iraient bien dans telles tel tel
environnement est ce que c'est
envisageable qu'il soit drafté à tel
niveau et ainsi on va pouvoir esquisser
un dessin de ce qui se fait tout en haut
de la draft donc on vous donne rendez
vous ce sera donc on rappelle la loterie
lé 17 et les live ont théoriquement
commencé le 19
on vous embrasse tous merci beaucoup
allan hughes jus d'avoir été là c'était
un plaisir comme d'habitude un podcast
très complet sur cetto m'bengue rennes
le joueur de gonzaga n'hésitez pas à
partager si ça vous a plu à nous mettre
des bonnes notes aussi grâce à vous on a
quand même gagné 2 euros 89 au moins
d'avril sur les écoutes donc à partir de
là bas c'est que c'est que du bonus
c'est que du bonus bisous à tous